SHOULD BE FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE.
>> Brian: SO YOU KNOW, THEY
HAVE DISCOVERY, TOO.
GAME ON.
LET'S MOVE ON.
THE BOOK "CHASING HILLARY,"
AMONG THE COURTS TO EMERGE "THEY
WOULD NEVER LET ME BE PRESIDENT,
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HATE ME QUOTE
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HATE ME QUOT"
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HATE ME QUOTT
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HATE ME QUOTE
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HATE ME QUOTA
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HATE ME QUOTT
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HATE ME QUOTE
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HATE ME QUOTP
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HATE ME QUOTS
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HATE ME QUOTO
WHY DOES EVERYBODY HATE ME QUOTF
THINGS THAT BRING THE DNC DOWN.
TELL ME WHAT IS GOING ON.
DOES IT HELP OR HURT YOUR CASE?
>> THOSE QUOTES THEMSELVES, WHEN
THEY ARE STAND-ALONE AND THE WAY
THAT THEY ARE BEING PRESENTED,
OF COURSE, IT DOESN'T SOUND
GOOD.
BUT ANYONE THAT IS GOING TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT, WIN BY
2.9 MILLION POPULAR VOTES, LOSE
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE BY ROUGHLY
60,000 VOTES, IF THEY HAD SWUNG,
THAT IT'S A TOUGH WAY TO LOSE,
THAT HURTS, IT DOESN'T FEEL
GOOD, AND THAT IS WHAT SHE IS
EXPRESSING.
I CAN'T BLAME HER FOR NOT
FEELING GOOD ABOUT THAT.
YOU WOULDN'T EITHER IF YOU RAN
FOR PRESIDENT AND LOST LIKE
THAT, THAT IS A TOUGH WAY TO
LOSE.
YOU ARE RIGHT, LOOKING FORWARD
TO 2020, 2018 MIDTERMS, FRESH
IDEAS, FRESH BLOOD, THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE WITHIN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHO ARE
STEPPING UP.
>> Brian: A COUPLE OF THINGS.
I WANT TO DOWNLOAD ALL OF HER
EXCUSES.
I RAN OUT OF TONER.
I HAD TO START THE SHOW.
I GIVE SO MUCH CREDIT TO PEOPLE
LIKE AL GORE, WHO HAD HIS HEART
BROKEN, NEVER COMPLAINED AGAIN,
JUST HAD SOME FUN WITH IT ON
TALK SHOWS.
THEN YOU HAD RICHARD NIXON, WHO
KNEW THERE WAS SOMETHING UNEASY
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN ILLINOIS,